Aaron is with us in Jefferson City
Missouri hey Aaron welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show hi Dave how are you sir
better than I deserve what's up I got a
I'm in kind of a crossroads and I wanted
your opinion I have an opportunity to
advance in my company but there's one
problem my brother works for the same
company
he's been there for almost as twice as
long as I have and if I accept the
position or if I get the position it
will put him out of the job whoa because
I will become a boss and he cannot work
for me okay and he cannot work for you
by company policy that's correct okay
can they not move him to another
department no I'd be over the whole the
whole store okay you would have to
change how big a company is this about
seven eight billion I guess huge okay
all right and who has offered you this
position I've not been offered yet it's
pretty clear that I'm going to get it
though okay who are you having these
discussions with my superiors okay do
they know about this yeah they know that
they could possibly put another one of
their employees out of the position by
promoting yes and they won't make an
exception not due to company policy no
well you can company policies not a
federal law you can make an exception to
company policy that's that's ridiculous
I mean why would you want to promote
somebody who would put their own brother
on the street
that's a dumb leadership on their part I
mean they're asking you to be willing to
cut your own
brother's throat right that would be
correct yeah that's ridiculous
so you he would be able to move to a
different location but that's that's you
know that's about 30 30 45 minutes away
so you'd be able to transfer stores but
not in the same store and he's been in
that same store for a while
13 14 years I've been there for almost
seven yeah
and so what about you taking a different
store I've thought about that you know
that's kind of a that's kind of a tough
one for me and so we would both be in
the same situation we both are based in
the same city and and they're they're
both commutes if we were to stay with
the company yeah yeah but I mean this is
not your brother's fault and he was been
there longer than you and this is this
company being stupid it really is so I
would go back to your supervisor and say
I can't do this I'm not going to cut my
own brother's throat I'm just not gonna
do it and so you guys need to make an
exception to your policy in order to
promote me why would and then I would
ask him why would you want a leader
running one of your stores that would
kick his own brother in the stomach I
don't want that guy working for me you
know and so you don't want to be that
guy no no this is stupid corporate
culture is what this is and these
leaders need the leaders above you need
to make an exception to this to show
that they have character I mean I get
that you wouldn't hire I don't hire
siblings I don't hire family members
here and we have our policy is almost
never because occasionally I do but it's
about one out of a hundred times because
it's fraught with danger it's very
difficult for you to lead a store with
your brother there I
get that would your brother work for you
no he would not he wouldn't want to know
he wouldn't want to
oh that's leave him being there twice as
long so this is going to hurt his
feelings is what you're saying
yes that's 100% correct that's actually
where I'm at I don't know if I should do
what's best for my family or okay you
know that's a different discussion then
okay so um you know your brother should
wish for your success
not be envious of your success and if he
can't do that then that's on him but
that's different than hey we can all get
along with this company's too stupid to
make an exception that's a different
different rant on my part then that's
now back on your brother so but I still
even though it would hurt his feelings
I mean if you could go in there and he
chose to not work there because you were
the leader then that's his decision but
for you to force him out because of
company policy I wouldn't do that
and so I I tell you what I would do
let me try let's start again then now
that I've got this extra information
again go back to your supervisor and say
I think if you will make an exception to
this policy that you won't have to when
you promote me he will leave and go to
another store or he will quit but that's
his decision
you didn't boot him onto the street do
you see what I'm saying yeah
he's got to decide he's gonna man up and
not be a jealous little brat about his
own brother succeeding right and if he
didn't want to that if he wants to stick
his lip out and go well just you know
cuz I've been around here breathing air
longer than you I should have gotten the
promotion well if you should have got
the promotion - you would have gotten it
so that's not but but you take that job
with the option for him to stay there
knowing you and your supervisor knowing
that he likely won't he'll likely move
to another
or quit right yeah you think I'll just
quit yeah I think he would he would just
get mad and quit yeah he's kind of
arrogant yes this is the guy that burns
down his own neighborhood to protest
right yeah I'm gonna show you I'm gonna
quit my job
Oh Lord well they see that those are
that those are his problems you're not
responsible for his problems unless you
create them by putting him out of a job
but I wouldn't put him out of a job if
he chooses benefit my even if my family
no even if even if it would benefit your
family I would take another store and I
would commute to not cut my own
brother's throat but you're not cutting
his throat if you've worked it out to
where he can stay there but he chooses
not to see he's still gonna get pissed
if you take another store because he's
just that guy that doesn't want anybody
else to win if he's not winning right
that's correct yes no so he still day
that he has had done opportunities that
he has not taken advantage of and it
fast yeah got the same company yeah he's
gonna be mad no matter what happens
because you're gonna go get a store and
I'm not gonna not take the promotion
just because he's gonna be mad that's
not the issue you see you see where I'm
drawing the line yeah and so I would ask
my supervisor I say listen I really want
to take this promotion but I need some
help I need a on the slim chance that he
would stay I need a temporary or a long
term exception to this policy and let
him stay but I'll give you a real high
probability he's just gonna quit or he's
gonna want to move to a different store
because he won't work for me and and but
otherwise you're putting me into a
position that I booted my own brother
into the street without him making the
choice and I can't be that guy
and I think you have that conversation
and you say you would want me to be that
kind of a leader that cares about not
only my family but the team that I'm
leading you want me to lead well and and
you know be concerned about the you know
the well-being of the team you wouldn't
want me to be a leader if I would cut my
own brother's throat I wouldn't want you
to peek even if it benefits your own
family but again if he gets mad or he
gets his feelings hurt and he makes some
dumb decisions that's his fault that's
not yours that's different then for no
choice of his he gets put on the street
there's a difference there's a different
line there in the sand so that's a
difficult one to work through it but
it's an interesting discussion thanks
for calling